tout ce sont 80 pompiers de montréal qui
ont décidé de prendre leur retraite hier
soir quelques heures à peine après le
dépôt du projet de loi qui va modifier
éventuellement les régimes de retraite
et françois on se demande aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ces pompiers
avaient ou craignaient de perdre mais
disons qu'en partant maintenant les
pompiers savait exactement avec quel
montant il s'en alla la retraite mais
s'ils décident d'attendre et bien là il
ne le savait pas parce qu'il se portait
garant entre autres d'une partie des
déficits à venir
donc dans le doute il y en a 80 qui ont
décidé de choisir l'option de partir
tout de suite sur 450 qu'ils étaient
éligibles
mais comme vous le dites c'est une perte
importante d'expérience au service 5
centimes on aime aller nous était
pompier à la ville de montréal et jeudi
soir comme 80 de ses collègues il a
décidé de prendre sa retraite à la toute
dernière seconde
parce que c'est mon cas soit il a vidé
sa case dit au revoir à ses collègues
c'est normal même gratifié le syndicat a
expliqué aux pompiers éligibles à la
retraite que le projet de loi du
gouvernement couillard risquait d'avoir
des conséquences pour eux des pompiers y
avait un risque énorme de pertes
financières et même de perte de
planification au niveau de leur âge dans
votre pour éviter ces conséquences
il fallait signifier son départ à la
retraite avant minuit jeudi soir les
pompiers n'ont eu que quelques heures
pour prendre une décision il est à
minuit minuit nuit en actes leurs l1 qui
leur est de prendre une décision comme
je les aime à le travail était dédiée
aux chargeuses des citoyens l'opposition
à l'hôtel de ville et inquiète parce que
ceux qui partent sont des pompiers
d'expérience ils se demandent comment se
fait-il que personne n'ait vu venir le
coup
c'est surprenant que le ministre ait pas
calculer c'est le genre d'événement qui
puisse arriver avec le dépôt de son
projet de loi
le syndicat dit qu'il avait prévenu tout
le monde me choque adage là-bas visage
d'ange et la vague yé le maire se veut
rassurant aucune caserne ne sera fermée
loquin d'un la sécurité des gens et mis
en jeu le premier ministre y voit un
certain jeu syndical
il rappelle qu'il faut faire quelque
chose pour régler les déficits des
caisses des régimes de retraite
on peut pas laisser 4 milliards d'
impasse et a des municipalités pas si le
contribuable payeurs de taxes qui
avancent le fait chaud le maire coderre
lui n'a pas voulu se prononcer sur le
contenu du projet de loi
il préfère attendre à lundi en compagnie
d'autres maires dont régis la bombe ici
françois qu'hormis radio canada montréal